that guy is willing to do whatever it  takes to win this fight I don't know if  Al Jermaine Sterling is willing to do  that the amount of drive that TJ dilshaw  has very few athletes have in all sports  Toby had it Jordan had it they're all  [ __ ]  DJ's not gonna win any nice guy Awards  with his friends he is his family he's  the [ __ ] best  trading partner stuff like he's gonna be  tough man because he has one goal only  and that's to be the very very [ __ ]  best and he'll do whatever it takes to  be the best  he's a comeback story if you don't view  TJ dilshaw's a comeback story you're a  hater you ain't [ __ ]  TJ's earned this  TJ's walk through the fire TJ's taking  all the criticism he owns all that he  paid his dues move on